so we did good morning mutt club you can
go watch that full show from this
morning but now you get the full evening
show this is available for everyone
who's a member of Mudd Club of course
behind the paywall plays TV every week
for the month of April or I guess really
a march 30th through May 1st you get all
of it because we wanted to get back to
you we know that you're isolated getting
a little bit stir-crazy
so the hashtag is mug club quarantine
and in order to continue staying afloat
and serving during this time if you
enter in the promo code at ladder with
credit com / mug club you enter the
promo code quarantine get $30 off of
course for the scheduled evening and
morning shows that are available here on
YouTube and blazed with a lot of credit
calm /schedule subscribe to Crowder bits
iTunes podcast all that this is going to
be an installment of life advice enjoy
the show enjoy the show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the PEC deck dance because
we're going to get to life to us a
little boy the guy he used to go in high
school and put all of the weight on the
PEC deck to show how strong you are
he'll show until he tore his PEC because
I was very ill-advised to use an
isolation machine for maximal strength
he still has breast tissue from it yeah
just the one side hanging so in other
words Sam this is really more of a PSA
don't do this with a lot of weight a lot
of calm this is uh this is a
continuation of course of mug Club
quarantine shows everybody would love to
come /schedule promo code quarantine you
get $30 off how are you Jill Morgan Jim
doing well
yeah are you now I am sorry you weren't
here this morning that's true yeah and I
paid the price my friend you did pay the
price I wasn't invited
really no we told us you were gonna be
very busy because you're moving into a
new house well that part's true you're
gonna be a father you know every other
exchange in the book I mean the business
happens whenever air quarantine Lane
school of thought never washes it okay
before we move on to no tomorrow
tomorrow we have a razor fist in the
show by the way wait I was talking I
drink water it went down the wrong path
went down the wrong pipe
bs I feel like every time someone coughs
I still live here you like Glenn Close
in exactly which what have you doubted
me she was dating a lot of people didn't
realize that go back and watch that in
hook it's Glenn Close with a beard yeah
today that would be anti-trans you
couldn't do that ooh
that's true so I know that you are all
very lonely I get that you guys are a
little stir-crazy so are we and so we
decided to give you more content than
ever just please do consider signing up
at the the ripe price of I think it's
like 12 cents a day when you add it up
with the 69 dollars a year promo code
just because we're not monetized on
YouTube the quarter black hair is gonna
have to take 77 cents on the dollar but
is minority she'll take it lying down
I want my reparations my question so
here's my question today we're going to
move on and talk about the whole YouTube
landscape and network television
landscape the corona buyer it's
essentially forced all late night hosts
now to become youtubers so today in 2020
thanks to karana we are all youtubers
how do you think these hosts stack up
you know what I know you're gonna say
they suck so I need a more pointed
question specifically which host do you
think stacks up the best without a
massive staff an audience laughter Q's
Colbert Kimmel Noah who do you think
silver lining here silver lining
obviously we're not we're not happy
about the coronavirus now of course is
we're not saying the silver lining is
that it has exposed late night hosted
and want to be late night hosts on CNN
on the most trusted name in news just
for that I wouldn't say talentless but
the lazy hats that they are and that's
why we're trying to do things a little
bit differently definitely here we see
that all of these folks who have all the
staff all this budget they're just
broadcasting from their bathtub now
they're just broadcasting from home and
we decided you know want we can take an
acceptable risk we can come in here we
can quarantine in the office we can
quarantine at home and try to make sure
that you aren't just left out in the
cold because Colbert can't find it was
in him as he shuffles past the 15
million annual salary to find a
microphone that he could use to
broadcast so let's go right now to see
in case you don't believe me just how
lazy late night has become to help
prevent the spread of kovat 19 I'm now
shooting the show with a safe minimal
crew of my husband and the creatures of
the forest hello everyone and welcome to
late night from NBC my hallway Tonight
Show I'm so excited to be doing he's not
supposed to go to a kindergarten mean
he's the cubby capable guest to my
bathroom behind your host Stephen
Colbert you're watching the very
social distancing edition of The Late
Show or as I now call it the lather show
with scrub and Colbert sir I'm doing the
show for my howl in New York and this is
how crazy New York traffic is I'm doing
the show for my living room and I was
still 20 minutes late getting in I'm uh
the loosening of the camera guys you've
isolated yourself okay hey man don't you
ever let me catch you prescribing didn't
my ward cool never funny accidentally
let me get that never stumbled across
funny Trevor Noah my first guest tonight
as you can see is mr. bubble followed by
a musical performance by the legendary
duo head and shoulders thanks guys I
don't like it I don't want it shut it
off and here's something so we'd never
know a lot of you will not realize us
people who haven't performed we've had
this struggle quite a bit when people
are truly taking part in sketches here
because a lot of people here aren't
actors and we're kind of fitting them
and I would love you me if they've
performed in rooms for example or in a
green screen room that's supposed to
take place outside yeah where people
sort of talk like this and I don't know
listen people don't see you in a studio
in a green screen room they're going to
see you outside in the forest or they're
going to see you in a crowded mall
that's what we're doing with the green
screen so you need to project right you
need to project the kind of volume in
the kind of intensity that your audience
is expecting given that scenario because
a lot of people get an industry talking
like this
that's what Trevor Noah's doing yeah
he's doing his show as though his wife
is mad in the next room I don't know if
he's married his boyfriend's mad max run
yeah if he catches 2020 it's just when
you take away the hype the hundreds of
employees writers producers they don't
have got nothing they can't do it for a
reference point by the way oh we're
talking about this a single episode of
Trevor Noah show has 21 writers 14
producers cast members technical crew
all that when you look at the entire
staff of a show like Colbert's you're
talking about
over a hundred people and the budget
these shows have tens of millions of
dollars tonight's show alone is 75
million dollars
75 million dollars you couldn't find a
camera guy who had more than an iPhone
and sitting laughs like Jimmy Fallon
right behind the camera it's terrible
when it's in front of the camera but
behind the cameras yeah stop and hear
something - I like this should have
caught them off guard right I mean they
they knew that something
like this was coming with the corona
virus out there right it didn't have a
technical team that said hey give us
give us half a day we'll set your house
on they do not respect the audience this
is the issue I don't think they respect
the audience you these hosts make
millions some of them make over 10
million dollars a year that's important
to note they could forego half of that
salary yeah to have someone set up a
remote studio by the way this everything
here ever this entire office the people
out there in the Edit Bay this entire
studio are Muslim we could do all of
that for a fraction of their salary and
it would be much better quality right
now
yes there's hours hours could always I'm
very confused as to what we're talking
about was related but the point is
Trevor Noah wouldn't know funny if it
swam up hit him on the ass in cape town
he wouldn't be funny if he try to think
Colbert has been funny Jimmy Kimmel can
be funny but it is remarkable to me and
I understand this idea of social
distancing but why can they not set up a
home studio or at least just get a mic a
mic mic Seth Meyers yeah yeah the
closest thing we have in late night is
like hurricane sandy that pushed through
and they recorded to basically empty
audiences for a couple of nights I think
right Fallon did Dave Letterman did Dave
Letterman did a show that was basically
much more just sort of interactive
between him and Paul basically making
fun of the fact that there was no
audience there it was it was funny that
the jokes fell flat he was like
basically it's like you know shame there
are 500 people here to listen to this
quality that's the way to do it but
they're they're hyping it up and acting
as if right there's this huge audience
or not stressing right the elephant in
the room yes which is it's an elephant
with a sign on it that says watch tiger
kid yeah turn this off and here's an
important note too because I'm kind of
joking about it but we're all youtubers
they don't stack up well they're not
doing well their views aren't good when
you remove the pay views it's even less
when you remove the when you remove the
algorithms which favor them because
they're advertiser friendly it's even
less Celia one thing we also know about
Trevor Noah horrible horrible design
horrible decor is it modern is it
contemporary I don't know but he has a
pube stache so I guess he's not gay I
have no I you know it doesn't work right
he could just be the man and he could be
the man in the couple you could just
began okay why are you so prejudiced
design that's like assuming that an
uncharacteristically high number of them
get AIDS except less accurate so and
companies NBC ABC CBS NBC Vox right
universal credit then ABC is Disney gosh
we've been in lawsuits with all of these
naming your lawyers in digital court
right now they're all trying to squeeze
YouTube in Google right trying to get
them to favor these shows you know cuz I
think they they know that they don't
have this stuff to compete that's why
they want to force shows like this that
not just shows like this but there are
plenty take examples like PewDiePie tell
you examples of whoever there just to
turn on a camera insert live-streaming
video games and I think there's there's
a race to the middle right there's a
split the difference with some pre
produced content some decent budget but
also hopefully talent now by the way hit
the notification bell if you are not
joining my club of course mug Club
quarantine is the promo code for the
month but his a notification bill had
all notifications because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot and do subscribe
to Crowder bits because that will be
will be uploading a lot of content extra
stuff over this month here's something
else that I think it's really showcased
not only how unfunny they're I mean I
don't think we need a coronavirus to
pull back the curtain on Sunanda yeah
it's not a big reveal no I don't think
so so much of anything for hers is an
improvement yeah
the best show she's done in a while
though because no one's watching it's
what I'm saying like it's an improvement
because if a horribly unfunny diversity
hire screams alone in a forest so their
production value has gone down and they
don't respect their audience we adore
you we genuinely do we are so grateful
they've also become lazier and this is a
silver lining and hiding their political
bias so yeah Kimmel had former
presidential candidate Pete but gig on
to host his show initially when they
were concerned about the Chinese virus
here you go now this is a strange night
for us not only because this is my first
time hosting a talk show because we are
doing it without a regular studio
audience due to public health concerns
over the corona
two staffers cancelled the studio
t-shirts let's do this together
who's what here's this big joke watch
full disclosure none of those people are
here but when you don't have a real
audience you have to fake one
just like Trump's inauguration big goofy
smile screw you Pete
screw you hard screw you hard with
someone else's peckers my point
I want nothing they're having why else
why would you have P but gig on if not
there's trying to push a political
agenda right now they used to try and
obfuscate a little bit no no we're just
going for comedy really okay so you're a
late-night show and you're just chasing
comedy new thought sub host Pete bucket
that is like there's no like stand-up
comics in the road who would have the
most horrible opener just to guarantee
job security what's going on or Jimmy
Kimmel actually think speak but gig is
funny or he's pushing a political agenda
you decide which one is more offensive
none of them are good another good
option and now here you go yours is this
another Kimmel yeah that's right you've
been interviewing people from his home
and here you go he is again at one point
you're trying to say well it's not about
left or right it's about being a human
as he cries about Cecil the lion now
he's basically been helping Biden tape
awkward campaign commercials that's
what's become Joe Biden what's that how
do you have on a New York Mets
supposed to be opening day way to be
able to sleep with my wife
well is a feeling girl oh she likes the
Hat do you think they don't brand-new
hate you or do you think he will try to
dodge that I don't know I hope we debate
I'm looking forward to that I don't
think you are Joe I don't think you and
your locked off a Cheshire cat alarm
clock mouthpiece really want to debate
Donald Trump it is remarkable tonight in
well
what if I want to sleep with my wife a
fish she's a nine year old filly girl
she's a girl you go from Philly what
what happened why'd I stop again it is
remarkable to me that in all this I've
been what do they have won if they have
Donald Trump on right they could have
had a lie don't care if they're chasing
the funny I don't care but listen can we
be honest here whether you agree with
President Trump or not by every
available metric it's going to be a
funnier show then it's going to be with
Joe Biden yeah if you agree with him or
if you don't he's way funny it's going
to be funnier well and I get like these
guys are doing something that's a little
bit different from what they're used to
right and basically they're saying that
we're the best but they have all the
budget they have all the staffers you
take away all of that and you find out
they're not the best do that do they
need some reps to get there because they
it seems like they have no sense of
timing they have no sense of what's
funny and what's not when there's nobody
in the room like do you think this will
get better if it goes on or will it just
continue to reveal how bad no I don't
think it'll get better I think that they
really believe this is sort of a gimmick
like that's it so it really just
discovered raw content yeah new Jim look
you never even just watched an old rerun
of Dick Cavett like this is new it's raw
it's what the people want you have no
it's what the people want if it's
conversational with someone interesting
right this is another problem every time
they can hear he has a podcast like
maybe we just run that we just let the
mics and we just talk okay but there
should be a selection process before
that like there is I don't think that
there should be gatekeepers in media
because we've talked about this of
course I never be able to host a many
main Network and of course conservatives
just told me for a long time that
conservatives don't like comedy so we
started doing this show and thank God we
found you and we are supporting up by
foreign calafate put you with the mugs
so I don't know I have no idea how how
if they're able to accurately assess
there are capabilities or if they think
this is good I don't know how they could
think this is good I mean maybe do it
once like that and it's like okay it's
raw it's funny but then get better if
you don't get better like you've got to
go okay we just can't do this John
Danaher once said it's hard to get out
of bed it's 6:00 in the morning when
you're sleeping in silk sheets and I
don't think our silk sheets are going
with Jimmy Kimmel could be rubber sheets
yeah I don't know but I I don't think
they have the motivation surrounded by
sycophants their whole lives or at least
for the last deck well and they all act
as if it's this close
interesting take on things but
everybody's doing the same thing right
they're all the internet yeah they're
all broadcasting from their phones or
holding up their laps right walk right
in their house and it and yeah and so
again they act as if this is some
discovery that they've made right and
something else too let's go to another
late-night host but you know he wants to
be see do we that's right it's always -
lets it's like I feel like a carnival
barker guessing someone's weight because
it's always different every broadcast
with brian Stelter hearing is having
Stephen King on with the chyron when
real life is even scarier than fiction
let's watch this Stephen thank you for
being here I wonder what what you say
about annex you looks like an area denim
- lesbian something Steven came
transitioning - woman well actually I
did imagine it I've heard a lot about
there three or four weeks people are
saying to me we're living in a Stephen
King world and all I can say is well I
wish we were really this is a Stephen
call a second this is a Stephen King
world and truth is stranger than fiction
we're talking about a virus that is at
this point at the point of this
recording nowhere near the magnitude of
a rough flu season you had a film with a
rapist clown troupe and just stand where
99% of him right 300 people left we're
waiting that with the sniffles yeah and
the reason they are is because they want
to blame it on Donald Trump they want to
act as though well this is actually
worse than the stand this is actually
worse than than it that's right that's
what I was called yeah yeah this is
worse than it because it's Donald
Trump's fault you don't mention of China
by the way if Stephen King wants to talk
about some sinister plot right some
world order some global conspiracy how
about the people who lied about the
virus in the first place and kill the
guy who tried to blow the whistle
couldn't that deserves a few pages in
there
no couldn't you include it in the
foreword Stephen King someone little he
writes him as he goes he was right you
read some as he goes and he doesn't know
how they end runs why he's done nothing
good outside of the shawshank
redemption' in potentially the Green
Mile prison really is that's where he
belongs
Stephen King is prison send him to
prison and we'll
another good Stephen King novel that's
not too much to ask well listen we've
thrown out rule of law we've thrown out
individual rights and freedoms right now
because everyone wants to give it up
because of ack off at this point with a
mortality rate of under 1% why don't we
just why don't we just give give Stephen
King the - to sues a treatment put him
in a federal prison I mean all Dinesh
did was give five ten thousand dollars
to a friend senatorial or congressional
campaign who didn't even win anyway
which by the way may not be as
derivative as the original Shawshank as
it relates to Escape from Alcatraz
it was the same film it was better done
but it was the same tomb going through
the whole emptying the little concrete
the plaster through the hole in the
pockets a white guy and a black guy
it was Escape from Alcatraz that's what
Shawshank Redemption was that being said
I liked it I didn't like it or it - how
long you been holding on to that but
when I see him looking like an angry
lesbian salon artist it makes me it just
brings it out of here and this is partly
dead in that scene I'm sorry it that the
great over everything so he just bizarre
he looked like every I knew ain't when I
would know angry middle-aged
french-canadian lesbians they all had
that grey hair with kind of the bangs
that came over like here like the little
cowlick
and yeah it should be noted - that he's
very feminine that's true he's very
feminine but in all bad ways and these
nopales he's not mysterious he's not
attractive
he's just maggie and kurt stacks up the
best out of all these shows i want you
to tune in for a little bit i'm sorry
just a little bit flip through CNN Fox
News ABC NBC CBS all the late night
shows and tell me who you think is doing
the best job adapting right now and is
this is important because it's not the
strongest animal that survives it's the
animal who can most effectively adapt
and we've consistently tried to do that
and be ahead of the curve not because
we're afraid of going away but because
we really do live to serve you guys we
always think hey listen we have been
supported from the ground up from
viewers you have created this show we
weren't thrust upon you by a network who
decided to put us on timeslot that
people were watching anyway and so we've
had to earn
we've had to earn your viewership these
people don't now you see how lazy they
are and that's why of course we're
offering this month the whole month free
bug Club month hashtag bug Club
quarantine Orange we're doing Monday
through Thursday evening shows available
on YouTube in front of the pay while
we're adding three shows a week and got
a lot of programs less scheduled every
Monday Wednesday Friday April 10 a.m.
Eastern and Crowder bits applet we are
trying to give you as much content as
possible and I appreciate a lot of you
saying you know look out for your health
I am I'm treating it like two-a-days I
am sleeping right I am eating right and
I'm very very unhappy but as long as I
am serving you because all you have this
is the reason we're doing this because I
I watch late-night religiously I have to
yeah it's not months you don't know how
dark it's inside my head sometime okay
and so because of that I was going this
is all this is all this is all everyone
has out there we have to give them more
and so we're going to give you
everything we have this month because I
know a lot of you are out of work I know
a lot of you run businesses that may not
open up again anytime soon and so if I
have to work 12 14 16 hour days for a
month you know what I'll take it if it
helps you guys and then I'll have a long
weekend it is mug Club quarantine promo
code quarantine $30 off these people are
really bad let's go to life advice where
we can help some other people might be
hurt please
with guru Crowder I'm glad to be with
you as I was just before that I'm not
glad to be back not I am not a doctor
no I will tell you because screw
honestly I'm a guru that being said if
you need a doctor for whatever reason if
you are thinking of anything here any
kind of help that would require the help
of medical professional of course I am
not qualified to dispense that sort of
advice or prescriptions not stuff so
stop asking I have some yeah stop asking
really I mean just I can't get you the
the zannies for the perky's yeah
percocet anymore that always called
perks perks perks any of the xanies or
perks or over leads or any of the oxen
don't you make those I don't have any
oxen pretty much I got all these you
know all of the beasts of burden I am
fresh out hmm
don't covet Cheerilee mug Club member
thank you oh it matters true start
making that up I even recently had a
family event and my mother-in-law fell
and severely hurt herself was broken we
all had the immediate only if it's funny
when it's just broken bone and torn
ligaments but see that doesn't
necessarily negate yeah the funny and
you only see it afterward it's true this
happened to my mom really well she had
my house and was it funny was Alvin
well she we were not laughing okay she
did afterwards though she was afterwards
and then realized she broke her knee Oh
was she okay yeah she had surgery what
kind of surgeries yeah I don't know
there's something it was like a knee
surgery well he wins
hey mom what kind of surgery did she
just turns when she has an ear oh my
gosh
go back control-z alright she fell while
leaning to pick up my child knocking my
child over in the process huh
however another relative for myself
family witnessed her fall and said she
was holding my child who was 11 months
old my mother lost 300 pounds and is not
allowed to watch my children after two
years of safety she's poor discipline
and a general disrespect for my husband
and me as parents my relative does not
know any of this and has no reason to
lie she brought me my crying child and
did say that my mother-in-law fell on my
child immediately after the incident I
am unsure if there was another witness
to the incident and do not want to bring
this to everyone's attention because I
have not told my husband do I bring this
to his attention or just let it go
her holding my child explains how she
injured herself so badly but do i gain
anything by bringing this to light or
will it just upset my husband keep in
mind she guilt trips him all the time
about not being allowed to watch her
kids blames a decision entirely on me we
made the decision together and held off
because we knew the blowout would be
enormous did not take any responsibility
for her behavior and decisions she has
literally said I don't know why she
doesn't want me to watch them and has
yet to address any of her grievances
with me this incident does not help her
cause okay
wow so sounds to me like it was funny I
will say that this one is is uh it's not
easy to execute easy to live out but
it's an easy solution kids come first
yeah yeah kids come first and negligence
can still be abuse yeah in this case or
even neglect it let's take another step
further can be abuse ignorant can be a
form of abuse and even it's so intense
doesn't really matter here if your
mother is a danger to people yeah and I
would just explain that to her if she's
a danger to people another law mother
mother-in-law sorry I would just explain
if she
a danger to your children she can't be
around your children or you know what
maybe split the difference and she can
hold your kids if you're supervising cuz
that is something important her she does
want to happen maybe if she has a
problem with you and your husband she
would not have a problem with your kids
she could be a great-grandma I've known
people like that so I knit safety first
I wouldn't leave her in a room on
supervise with your kids just like by
the way never leave a kid you'd a kid
with a dog you don't know on supervisor
right
some people think like oh my kid gets
along with my dog that's true but I see
parents do this all the time some people
do it too they've done it with with
Betty they did it with hopper thank God
then obviously they're fine that being
said I would sit there like I cannot
imagine this I cannot imagine being a
parent leaving my child with a dog that
I don't know that well know especially a
dog the size of hopper or Betty so I'm
consistently amazed sometimes if some of
the decisions that that parents make
that my parents were very clear on like
myself I always knew that my safety came
first yeah that's what comes first with
your mother-in-law so I don't know hard
she's not gonna like it but I would be
as straightforward as possible you
absolutely have to bring a Madeline
yeahbsolutely have to bring this to your
husband's attention because your mom
fell on your kid yeah sure yeah I mean
it's a it's a tricky situation in the
execution of making sure I know I said
the mom yeah making sure that this this
takes place so the answer is absolutely
true you you have to take the kids
safety first but then the next part
comes if she's blaming you for this that
means your husband has got to do a
better job of communicating with his mom
this is not my wife being mean or cruel
this is us saying that this is a
dangerous situation mom your son me I am
saying I don't want you watching our
kids by yourself because we love you we
want you to be around the kids but these
are unsafe situations and unless we can
mitigate those we can't do this there
has to be a very adult conversation he
seems like he needs to step in the way a
little more and make sure that she's not
being blamed like all that evil wife of
yours is just not wanting me to see the
kids that's what it feels like from what
she said yeah so I think he needs to do
a better job of getting in the way of
that I also this is just a personal
belief I think that a lot of folks in
family citas just sort of a rite of
passage like well I'm a grandparent now
therefore I get to do XYZ whatever I
write you know whatever oh no you don't
you don't you still need to be looking
out for the safe to the child and the
parent still have the right to make
those calls for the same reason if you
if you're a heroin addict in your
grandparent you don't get to be on
children's life sometimes the parents
have different standards than you do
sometimes the parents want to raise your
children differently than you do that is
their whether it's right or wrong in
this case I'm not saying that the
parents are wrong but sometimes they can
be wrong that still is their right and
if you have to make do as a grandparent
or give up being with the grandkids
right you know you got choices there
yeah sometimes people just think well
I'm a grandparent different no kids
should obviously respect all of their
elders including the grandparents it's
not the child's job to keep you in line
at all okay let's be clear about that
but it is reparent job to set boundaries
and let you know what is and what is not
okay and in the scenario not knowing all
of the history I mean this is a physical
danger - yeah 300 plus pounds and and
having issues with falling this isn't
the first time and all that saps I
wouldn't do it objective it is a
300-pound woman who wants to hold your
baby while she's sitting in your in the
room if you're not comfortable that's no
longer a safety issue because she's if
she's sitting she has good base okay
she's not she's at least so you so you
need to be consistent you communicate in
other words you can't say it like well
it's a safety issue she goes cool fine
I'll sit down I'll put the baby in a
brace and you're like well no she said
well she's gonna try and corner you
right say what you mean and be
consistent decide what the rules are
draw the boundaries and make sure you
stick with them but being less than
straightforward isn't going to help
because it's just going to create more
of a communication in line yeah
absolutely all right next one here we go
dear guru Crowder audio wade Gerald and
quarterblack a parenthesis though like I
mean I lost my dad at a fairly young age
I was 20 my dad was 50 talking to him
has always given me peace is that a bad
thing to him is in quotes I'm not sure
what that means he's the best friend I
ever had is there a chance you all can
really expand on the spiritual aspect of
things
my father was cremated unfortunately
that's a totally different family issue
but his ashley stay on my nightstand
I am the
thirty have three children and nobody
seems to be able to accept acknowledge
or be able to help me move on during my
darkest days I often feel like I'm dying
without him
to be with him yes give Betty cheese
please let that happens I love the
chance as much as hopper and she's also
learned a lot thank you very much I
think as well so anyway it's tough when
you lose a parent yeah I'm sorry to hear
that yeah absolutely it's a really
difficult process I think you know I
think it's been almost a decade since
that based on some of the stuff that I
saw in the letter that I didn't read I
think it's almost about a decade since
that happened I don't know that you ever
fully recover but you obviously move
closer and closer to getting some kind
of normal maybe a little bit of a new
normal as far as talking to your dad as
though he's still present and in the
room there are a lot of times where I
think that can be very helpful to to
think like that but then I also think
that there are some times where that can
be somewhat detrimental it keeps you
focused on maybe the past a little bit
more and not really living in the
present and being as present of a parent
you have three children right to be you
are that person to them only in the the
mother role and so I think sometimes it
can be a little bit detrimental to hang
on to those things there's a period of
mourning that we have to go through and
a period at which we kind of have to
move on and that's where you get a lot
of that healing from when you move on
into the normal things of life without
forgetting the past and without
rejecting it but putting it in its
proper place and saying I'm honoring the
memory of this person I remember them
fondly I think about them and when I do
it's good memories but I'm also sowing
into the now I'm sowing into my children
in the situations that I'm in and the
friendships that I have so if it ever
gets in the way of that and keeps you
from moving on
especially you said you have some really
really dark times I think it would be
helpful to continue through the rest of
the process and not stay where you are
in the process but that's just my take
on it well it depends what talking to
him as though he's still mean you I want
to be clear as far as a spiritual side
to explain you your dad can't hear you
right I don't have anyone here disagrees
with me on that spiritually I'm anyone
don't what do you think Wade I don't
think he's busy listening to every word
resan oh yeah yeah I don't know that
there's any scripture that tells me
that people that we are family members
with can hear and see what's going on in
lab I don't believe that that's true
and there's a lot but I just think about
it first as a lottery otherwise yeah
well I know they can't come back like in
a spiritual you can't call them back you
can't communicate with the dead or
anything like that well as far as like
what kind of view you have from the
mezzanine up there on what's going on
down here I have no idea but I'm
assuming it's not that your focus is on
earth you're you're in heaven yeah
that's right great focus to have up
there I don't yeah as far as from a
spiritual basis I see a lot to to not
only suggest but flat-out tell you as a
Christian that you cannot communicate
with anyone who is no period and i mattr
like i see a lot of prescriptions that
are pretty clear don't do that yeah
doesn't say don't do that for a dead
relative it says no don't do that period
yeah and here's what I will say though a
lot of people say oh man and it hurts um
let me be really clear do you really
think and this is I will I understand
where you're coming from to a degree I
still have both my parents but I watched
my mom lose both of her parents in the
span of a year and I was very closely
keepin give you an idea actually I grew
up so close to my grandfather it's
actually not as far from the back of
this building to the front of this
building right here I grew up for my
grandfather yeah so I stay there all the
time I was with my grandfather he was
when people say the second father I
don't think there would have been more
than two days that went by that I didn't
see my grandfather for significant
amounts of time every day he was my
favorite person so not the same thing
that being said I do think there's a
component of this listen you have
children you want them to feel this
longingly about you when you go away you
need to focus on your children and you
move on for your children you need to
move on for your husband you need to
move on for your family and when you
remove the and I say this respectfully
the selfish part of the equation it's a
good thing that your dad can't hear you
sweetheart
I mean that it's it's a good thing you
don't want your dad looking down right
now and seeing you in this much pain
what could possibly be more torturous
for your dead father than looking down
and seeing you miserable unable to do
anything because he can't communicate
with you right it may make you feel
better but that would be horrible
that would be like ripping the heart out
of your dad's chest so thank Christ and
I mean thank Christ in that he is
very clear that you cannot communicate
to the dead and that when you get to
heaven you are not longing for anything
of this world here's the thing that's a
good thing because that's a good thing
that that's the case because guess what
as soon as your dad crossed over through
those pearly gates whether figurative or
literal if he were to long for anything
of this world it would be you because
I'm sure they love you just like you
love him but he doesn't right now he is
completely fulfilled and that peace
which I know is much harder for you but
it's not hard for your dad so
spiritually your dad can't hear you your
dad is not and thank God your dad is not
having all this sort of offloaded onto
him all of your emotions because you're
still dealing with with the fleshly pain
and the the earthly concerns and desires
and turmoil that really he's long since
left behind something else - there's a
strong case to be made and I had a patch
or talked about this and on the verses
in front of me in heaven there isn't the
same concept of time that we have here
so as far as yes as far as your dad is
concerned you're walking through those
gates at the same time together yeah so
a very strong case yeah I'm a spiritual
basis I I feel it's one of those things
where people listen I hate and I'm gonna
sound like a hippie but open your mind
they go but wouldn't my date like I love
my dad so much wouldn't God want me to
be able to talk to my dad a dead
grandfather my dead father one second
you're trying to put this in a
three-dimensional rumor we have a God
who is past present future Alpha and
Omega you don't understand what heaven
is you don't know how many dimensions
there are and you are trying to put this
into a box that would be most pleasant
for you now there are new boxes that you
could have never even imagined before I
guarantee you that he is better off than
you could ever possibly compute and that
doesn't include in the equation as far
as what we believe biblically the
ability to communicate with you it's not
a part of the equation the equation is
far better than you're giving it credit
for yeah so this is a lot bit more
difficult for you than it is for him and
so I think the best thing that you can
do is like you said take the proper
steps to moving on and and start
focusing on other people first it sounds
to me like you're but it sounds like
you're a great mom that you care about
your kids that just sounds to me like
you have a great family I mean I would
imagine that if your dad were here that
would be really important for him for
for you to continue them continue with
that not really
to him he can't hear you yeah well and I
think too you know your dad would
probably want that for you yeah right
whenever whenever your parents leave
this earth they want you to be able to
function and to have a wonderful joy
filled life with your family or whatever
the situation may be with you and so use
that as motivation like well what would
my dad want me to do right now will he
want me to be thinking about the past
and living in pain from this situation
or would really want me to remember the
good things about the time that we had
together and move forward and take some
of the lessons that I learned and create
a legacy that reflects on him as well as
me yeah you know like I think you're
right and that's super hard you know I
mean in those types of situations
especially at a young age that this
person lost I'm not super young but
young enough yeah pretty pretty early
it's just it's tough but the best thing
that you can do is to understand like
that's what that's the goal the goal of
being a parent is to raise a child that
can live on their own and have a good
life hopefully a life that is better
than yours yes what your dad would want
you to do and this is one thing I will
say that and I this is just me going off
of my own personal rant so I appreciate
you saying that you know this doesn't a
Sara Lee have to do with you but it kind
of is a narcissistic view of heaven when
people say oh I know my I know my dad or
I know my aunt or I know my son is
smiling down on me that's a pretty
crappy heaven especially considering
that this is supposed to be very
temporary right way this is this is but
a moment when you think about eternity
this is this is very much second tier to
what goes on there as far as your
lifespan as far as all of eternity right
so we're gonna be designing from the
ground up for heaven to be right here
right this is fallen people have made
all kinds of mistakes and obviously we
understand what the end of the world
will well we don't understand fully what
the end of the world will look like the
winners and there will be an end of the
world and there will be a final day of
judgment but the point is to think that
heaven was created for this very
temporary space known as earth for
people just disappear like what's going
on down there like an Aquarian they
don't care yeah anything you we can't
but we should be concerned with what's
going on up there a whole lot more than
they could care about what's going on
down here
yeah yeah it would be very bad to have a
view from heaven to see all the pain on
earth yeah that's like thinking the
headliner should be watching every
single warm-up act No
yeah it's exactly this me okay alright
but and I'm sorry to hear of your loss
and I think that listen I think you know
we only see a snapshot into people's
lives here so sometimes or either ceylon
difficult being harsh or not from what I
read it seems like you you probably are
fantastic mother and I think that that
focusing on that and and also by the way
I would also test us on this read up on
theology read see if you believe if you
can find any justification look to the
scripture that that your father is able
to communicate with you and if you think
that we're wrong then let me know why
but speak with you know spiritual
advisors people whose spiritual counsel
you trust and go to the book and I think
I think you'll find more peaceful as you
actually get definitive answers okay
dear amazing all-knowing guru Crowder
and Gerald see oh not even me is true
well you know working work on your lamp
I feel my wife's grandfather passed away
three weeks ago and we haven't had sex
since oh they're all loaded freight holy
who's daddy and sex yeah exactly who
isn't we it's like weekend at Bernie's
my wife's grandfather passed away three
weeks ago and we haven't I assume you
mean you and your wife keeping it simple
how long should I expect to wait before
asking or bringing it up and seeming
like an inconsiderate a halt too late I
understand the grieving process is
different for every situation but I also
don't want it affecting our marriage or
should I just continue to go take care
of business myself it's since we heard
of you ready yeah and hold it okay
thanks one fresher let me just tell you
that you are an inconsiderate ass just a
wee bit
this is tough love this is not anything
love yes if you want easy love that's a
different show I understand that but I
don't care that much and they said if
you go take care of it of yourself which
one would presume there's probably some
level of that I don't think your wife
would hold it against you rather than
rubbing up against her leg all right so
let's talk about needs seriously right
so he he says in his letter he has a
higher sex drive and that this is a
thing that they have to work on okay so
you have a need right now you have a
need to be intimate with your wife your
wife this is a pre-existing condition
yeah I'm gonna say what Milton Berle
told a young Richard Pryor pick his
spots babe she has a need right now as
well she has a need for you to be there
to be with her for and if we in process
it's not yes it's yes she doesn't need
your 27 second rodeo okay she's not
looking for that right now what she's
looking for is her husband to be there
and to say look I know that this goes
beyond it now at a certain point you
guys do need to come together right
because it is good for a relationship
not to be apart like the Bible says I
think okay right don't you look apart
for a time but not for too long because
that's that's a problem sometimes yeah
because eventually this guy could go to
pornography and we've talked about that
in previous things right so anyway I do
think you need to don't be selfish when
it comes to sex I know three weeks
sounds like a long time especially for
somebody in y'all's age bracket that you
listed but understand that she's going
through something difficult don't be
selfish when it comes to sex and I would
also this women understand that you bear
part of the responsibility as well yeah
you cannot if this is a place existing
issue obviously these are extreme
circumstances where we had a death in a
family but I see a lot of women who
think well especially and I hate to say
this but especially in the church was
conserved women like well you should be
able control himself you you're playing
with fire if you just because you don't
have a sex drive you're not having sex
with your husband
you know going weeks without it you are
playing with fire and that you are
deciding to try and use whether
knowingly or unknowingly a biological
function of a man and by the way this is
something this is also something how
married
couples become closer don't do it I'm
not absolving women of responsibility
because no obviously the man should have
some self-control but if you do not have
sex with your husband repeatedly well he
should learn listen I don't know what
you expect to happen yeah yes Ramar says
not to give place to the devil I believe
yeah my my first question is has he
tried like maybe rubbing up against her
leg repeatedly three weeks in there
missing or there not like there's no it
seems like it would at least like make
an advance and does she just go no
because of the pre-exhaust
three weeks it's like you can talk about
it to their parent died no grandparent
grandparent okay well maybe I think it's
pretty weird
well here it look I think you talk about
it I think you you say hey like this is
this is an issue right now that we need
to talk about Kim I understand you're in
a grieving period can we talk about yeah
it might be an issue more so with you
because this is something's been going
on for a while yeah yeah because of
three weeks late it was a typical you'd
say well this is for a season I
understand it she's really upset right
it sounds to me like you're thinking
that maybe your wife you guys have kids
that's normal yeah three weeks kids stop
it starting with my parents I don't know
they've said so yeah they've been very
clear about it but that so I don't know
they keep talking about it I mean that
second trimester amazingness I think
it's just a warning that's happened yeah
I think you need in other words if
there's a mismatch here as far as your
sexual expectations and you feel that
maybe she's using this as an excuse then
that's an entirely different problem
that's the problem it's true and there's
and this is a problem that this is some
of this very politically incorrect it
does go both ways men you need to
control yourself if we're going to talk
about pornography women it is a part of
your wifely obligations what do I mean
by obligations it's a part of your
wifely duties to satisfy your husband
sexually if you plan on having a
successful marriage if you are you know
you're holding your c-section scar and
all right that's not what I'm saying now
if you haven't done considerate husband
has a problem but that being said if you
are looking for an excuse to not engage
your husband in sexual activity you are
making a mistake
yes so I have a question for you guys
the guy everybody's married in this room
obviously so we read a book sorry I
almost said I almost was like
Heatherette for those of you who are
married sorry I used to be the guy not
cool your jets you're a little new to
the club exactly I know right I know
everything guys loosen up
no we read a book that said something
that we both thought was pretty
interesting we're a couple in this a
christian-based book and he said look if
I go to my wife and for some for
whatever reason right she's like no I'm
not I'm super tired or just yeah I'm not
gonna be able to because of you know
whatever I mean my head doesn't matter
whatever it is they have a 24-hour rule
where they know that okay within 24
hours
no no agree to they've agreed for each
other to say look this is important
enough part of our relationship where
it's sacrificing one for the other and
so yeah I understand that right now is a
no and that's totally fine you have to
have the ability to say that but within
24 hours unless the the party that has
approached says you know look I know we
need to have a bit more time what no you
know that's necrophilia then after that
come on
so anyway no that's I thought that was a
really good rule it may be helpful for
he my wife and I had often and I don't
mean to sit but mismatched energies as
far as a lot in other words when I get
home from work I've been working for so
long that typically my bleep to talk
about a day oh my I don't want to talk
so we have to kind of set Simoes like
okay I get home you give me at least 10
minutes when I get to the door yeah and
obviously you know for me like I often
work from home if I literally don't like
I go home I check our messages okay when
you do as far as titling something I'll
kind of try and wrap some things up and
then after that is like 10 minutes for
me to do so what do I do to relax
typically speaking I'm a very simple man
either three or watching yeah cigars or
watching old like right now haven't
watch a lot of old boxing videos I don't
know if your face is really there I'll
read old sort of like Doc you all
reasonableness or how to's or watch some
old documentaries right now it's old
boxing videos like that it's cool I've
been going through the Duran Hagler
turns watching every fight watching
every analysis I can find on the fights
and then reading up on them it was just
very interesting to serve understand
this I enjoy snippets of history and
sort of immersing myself in that world
we have sometimes mismatched energies
after work where I don't know Sara Lee
want to talk and sometimes that is
sexually I will say this the worst time
I've talked about this in the show the
worst time for sex to me is later in the
day yeah that's when I'm just swamped
like I wish it was like an after like
the afternoon snack time afternoon
perfect time for difficulty with wakeup
sex like right in the morning
well you difficult you mean like
difficult it's far more difficult makes
it get into it so make it happen no
immediately upon waking
well I hold on do you mean like a
willing having a willing partner as well
no no no I mean to me you're okay yeah
no I'm right when I wake up I'm like I
need coffee no no I'm not that way oh
yeah I wake up immediately a lot of
times I'm like a window going which is
after this Jam in the morning and before
the end of the work day which makes it
very difficult it does so we schedule
that every day we do we have coping
mechanisms but back in but you do have
to sit down and talk about you do and it
is a problem that every married couple
needs to work out a lot it'll get
uncomfortable with it or they think well
I don't want to schedule sex sometimes
you got it helps you get in a rhythm on
it like it helps you understand the
other person and then you get in that
rhythm with them and the rhythm is gonna
get you it's gonna get you there I've
heard that you're right that was George
st. Pierre there was like one of those
cool cells like yeah he walked up he's
like I don't think Matthews can handle
my rhythm the Radames gonna get you
redux but it was the rhythms going to
get you
I just like to buy it with your money
you drank that he did or whatever money
money
that's your st. Pierre what a great
athlete all right so I don't know if we
answered your question
all right we tried don't try and mount
your wife immediately upon her relative
rights on the flip side if it's three
weeks have gone by and you're not
putting out come on sweetheart all right
wedding crashers said that you could be
the same thing for funeral you know like
the emotional state yeah that's what the
movie said yeah I'm white that's what
you start with Wow okay no dear off the
top yeah right off with sig Heil done
whoa I have a yeah you should get you
know what you should check your
insurance for all that sig hail damage I
am white I have a baby mama who's half
black and who and a wife who's from
Africa mama is a nightmare and my wife
has an absolutely incredible woman
inside and out okay the surgeon all
right she even lets me live in the house
huh
okay I think it's a joke I'm baby mama
or BM as I like to silently caller to
myself accuses me of being racist and
buying a slave wife who I can own I feel
like maybe I'm not the racist one here
but I keep getting told that I'm wrong
about that
and yes BM is voting for Bernie I could
really use your sarcasm to help clear
this one up for me thank you so much
first off I don't really use sarcasm
sarcasm is the lazy man's comedies true
that being said sarcasm isn't going to
help clear this up and what I'm about to
offer isn't going to help clear this up
so really she just you just close this
window this tab right now yes move on
I'm trying to make sense of this so give
a baby mama who's half black and a wife
who's from Africa well Africa is a very
large continent yeah it's out there do
you see a light reflector here I don't
think so are we talking Scarlett
Johansson and that's called the Manson
what's her name Charlie stares
right I mean you could be getting away
with some wordplay here a little bit
where it's a white South African and the
other one is half black and you're
trying to virtue Singh like you're not
racist but really Omar's out that it's
just tribal though I mean this is a
different story could be I mean let's
assume that you've plucked your current
wife straight off the cover of a
National Geographic
his World Vision kit we're supporting
your current wife at the price of less
than a cup of coffee for them and that's
great fantastic and then your other baby
mama is half black I don't really think
it should matter I mean I don't know
what you really who cares you racist I
know he's being accused of being a
racist and owning a quote-unquote slave
wife's would that makes my the Africa
wife is black realize it wouldn't make a
whole no I know I was just being
difficult
um I was trying to clarify understand
the only here's what matters what
matters is the child in that case right
because you're saying baby mama so you
have a child with this woman so what
matters is what's best for that child
and what's best is for you and the
mother to be civil to the best of your
abilities now that being said if you if
you can't be civil without completely
abandoning all of your principles or
everything at you stand for that's not
best for the child either because it's
gonna see a weak-willed father who
doesn't stand up for what's right so
it's not really that hard of a balancing
act you need to be respectful and
honoring of the BM as you call it
probably stop with that that
abbreviation there we said silently in
his head which I'm cool with okay that's
fine unless your kid has ESP in which
case that's you know what applies to you
all of them yeah honor the mother
respect the mother make sure that you
don't talk badly about the mother to
your child and make sure that your child
sees an example of a good strong father
your your child is going to be smart
enough to see if you are a racist or not
okay so how about this
I know what you just said the BM is
voting for Bernie Sanders yeah make fun
of Bernie Sanders
and make sure the child knows that the
BM is voting for Bernie Sanders
is that okay
that is underhanded cannot in and I
endorse because you're honoring the mom
like you've never said a bad word you've
only said that the candidate she chases
that link is do you want okay give me
the answer here there's the right thing
the real thing there's no right thing to
do which I've just clarify the fun thing
help you miss the fun I've often thought
about this if I wanted if I did if I
just do caution the wind I couldn't care
less about the right thing the most
effective thing to do that's what I want
would be to simply comment on Bernie
Sanders in a very reasonable but clearly
loaded way that it might go over a
child's head but be caught perfectly in
the catcher's mitt by your baby mama and
watch her flip out and then to your
daughters yes wow you see right thing to
do but it would work he needed a little
sarcasm
we gave him comedy yeah I don't I mean
honestly this is a tough situation this
is but doing the right thing is still
doing the right thing on an imam make
sure the kid honors i'm i make sure the
kid sees you ensuring that the ensuring
that the mother is respected by the
child make sure this is never any doubt
in the child's mind that if a tip that
there's a difference of opinion between
the child or mom that you will take the
site of mom regardless of the new wife
unless it's bernie i would imagine -
yeah and I would imagine that wonder you
want your baby or baby mama you're sorry
I'm getting you want your child have a
good relationship with your current wife
yeah so what do you think will be most
effective and what do you think is the
right thing to do to make sure that your
baby your child wants to spend more time
with you and your current wife and I
would behave that way
there you go yeah I think it's easy
enough yeah I mean we solved all these
problems that's pretty nice and you know
when the child walks in just place some
of our videos and Bernie Sanders let
them play in the background Mudd Club
subscription you did my Mudd Club I mean
I don't know place I'm also very
self-serving yeah maybe too much Club
subscriptions maybe - yeah there's no
added value in this scenario playing
them one with a slight delay there you
go so if they're sort of tough they're
always there like you have a phone on
Sprint just have the videos at the ready
when the BM comes to pick up the child
yeah but I mean you know the one thing
is you hear all these horror stories
about step parents
and it's like you don't want to be that
person a child a child doesn't
necessarily know they don't know
anything about politics they don't
necessarily know what's right but they
know how they feel yeah and so do what's
right and make sure that you find a way
to to frame doing what's right that
feels as attractive as magnetic to your
child as possible you want to be someone
your child wants to be around especially
as they go into their teenage and they
just happen to drop in
you know socialism doesn't work
everyone's one yeah yes yeah Justin
right and anybody who thinks it does is
usually a pretty stupid person except
could be a good spot you know if your
wife for example if your current wife
who's from Africa I don't know her
political leanings but I also don't know
that this person specify if the child is
a boy or a girl
so I said boy a minute ago okay but if
the child is a girl and this would be a
good thing for your wife to really
become friends with in your wife by the
way is not burdened with all the same
responsibilities of being the mother
because you your child has a biological
mother yeah so this is a scenario where
your wife can kind of be a friend right
parents don't get to be buddies but your
wife kind of does so your wife can be
friends out of course while obviously
still having a respectful relationship
and respect authority but your wife can
be friends with this child
and can also express what she was raised
with in Africa and the corruption with
those ends of government speak to it
firsthand so these are conversations
that can be had that don't need to feel
like loaded sort of political
indoctrination yeah that's what my
parents said they didn't in doctrine I
mean but they made me think about all
these issues they would ask me what do
you think about that what do you think
about those taxes what do you think
about the health care that you received
what do you think about abortion why
they would ask me those questions and
your wife may be a really valuable
sounds like she's a gem maybe a really
valuable asset here because she doesn't
have the same burdens associated with
her as you do as a biological father
yeah exactly
don't use the kid make what I'm glad
that you found they'll have a great
found a good woman I'm sorry about the
baby mama you don't sound racist to me
no and good for you
taking the tribe you ladies from the
Hutu Plains nice job all right
Center life we're going to go I believe
tomorrow tomorrow is either race that's
just something around just I think it's
a scrapyard show with maybe a guest I'm
not sure but it's gonna be fun
hey if you enjoyed this show subscriber
hit the notification but I'm cuffed it's
cold in here so I'm covering covering my
nips hit all notifications on the
notification Bell because apparently
notification subscriptions don't mean a
whole lot look their video what they're
playing in boxes those happen incredible
code their videos playing in boxes you
should click one of them maybe one of
them is a mystery box could cut glass
with these things